rondelle is in new york city hi rhondel
how are you
hi dave thanks for taking my call i'm
well how are you better than i deserve
how can we help
um so i am looking to so i just sold my
house
and i'm looking to purchase a new home
so i'm wondering if i should get
a two-family home that's going to be a
bit more expensive obviously real estate
in new york is
super expensive but i plan on renting
out half of it
and that income that i project should
bring me down to that
25 uh debt income ratio
so i was wondering uh what are your
thoughts on that or should i just go for
like a regular house
oh i probably would go for a regular
house and the reason
i would do that personally is a
two-family home
the good news is your renter is next
door and you can watch out for what's
going on the bad news is your renter is
next door
and if they want something that's gonna
be knocking on your door i mean it's um
so it's a it's a little bit awkward at
times to be in the same property
the other thing is a two-family home 90
of the time that it's it's sold is not
owner occupied
meaning it's going to be an investor
buying a duplex buying a two two unit
product and uh so your buyer
on that kind of a thing is always an
investor most always and it's therefore
they're looking for a deal
your buyer on a single family when you
get ready to resell
is retail it's joe and susie just got
married once that house or whatever
and so and they pay retail so single
families
of the exact same price will typically
appreciate
better than a duplex will just because
of who the end user is when you get
ready to flip out of it
but uh it's not a bad idea it's not the
end of the world but
you know sometimes all we look at is the
math and we're going oh the renter's
going to help me pay and that's going to
just be grand and it's like
no yeah it's so there's a lot of crap
involved and all that that's not going
to necessarily be fun
so um you know i
i probably wouldn't i wouldn't
personally
because of quality of life i just
wouldn't want to live right next door to
my renter
it's just i just personally wouldn't
want to do that and that's just and i've
got a bunch of rental property and i'm
not a snob i've been a renter that's not
the point
but i just that that's an awkward
relationship well it's the convenience
of what they have
towards you yeah yeah i mean you're
pulling in the driveway and they're both
phone in the right way and it's like you
know it's just
weird next-door neighbor weird
relationship so
but you can do whatever it's not a bad
thing but it's certainly not a slam dunk
oh yes
definitely take the income because
there's more to it than
than just that when you're when you're
renting property
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two and by the way there are
once you learn
how to work with people in the real
estate business
and you learn how to interview
a potential renter for one of your
properties like you were interviewing a
team member to come on board with your
company uh
it's not dissimilar you you can learn to
weed out
people they're gonna be a problem and
you can learn to put in really high
quality
folks a lot of the rental property that
we have rachel's husband winston runs
our rentals runs all of our real estate
and he does a great job screening the
tenants in
and it's not unusual for one of our
tenants to have been on a property five
years
and our friends they become friends
because they're good people
you know and so that you know you can
get
you know you never hear me say we're
putting down renters we're not
because i've been one and we work with a
lot of really high quality people
that for whatever situation at this
point in their life they're renting
so you can you can get if you do the
proper screening you can get a good
situation